[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
البرد لا يبدا ولا ينتهي بشكل مفاجئ فله
بدايه وشده ونهايه فبدايته مع موسم اصفري
شهر سبتمبر وشدته مع موسمي المربعانيه و
الشرطه ديسمبر ويناير ونهايته مع موسم
الحميم شهر ابريل والشتاء الفعلي 90 يوما
تقريبا 40 يوما المربعانيه و 50 يوما
مقسمه على الشبط والعقارب 50 عاما تولت في
تصرفها عسر يسرا على الحالين اشهده وما
ذقت زمان في تقلبه الا وفي زمن قد صرت
احمده وما جزعه على ميت فجعت به الا ضللتر
القبري
احسدوا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وخلال هذه الايام يدخل علينا موسم الشبط
والشبط ثاني مواسم الشتاء الفعلي
المربعانيه الشبط العقارب والشبت سميت
بهذا نسبه الى الشهر السرياني شباط فهو
يقع في فبدايته امتدادا لموسم الازيري
وسمي بهذا لان الاجساد تزرق من شده برودته
ونهايته بدايه موسم بذره الست والمربعانيه
الان جالسه توصي ولدها شقي شباط وتقول له
يا وليدي ترى مريت ما ضريت عليك باللي
اكله دويف وناره
سمر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]